[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i mentioned a couple basketball things
at the end of the hour i wanted to get
frank isola on who uh
covers the nba you see him on around the
horn pardon the interruption
and of course he has his serious xm nba
radio show called the starting
lineup monday through friday 7 a.m to 10
a.m
frank thanks for joining us on short
notice this gordon hayward situation
where he just turned down 34 million
dollars from boston
what is the plan that gordon hayward has
where is he headed well first of all
good to see you dan you look great
um you know clearly he's not part of
their plans which doesn't mean
that he still might not come back to
them for just one year
but there's no way that gordon hayward
is opting out of 34 million a year
unless he believes he can get a good
deal someplace else
so could that be the knicks could it be
the atlanta hawks is he looking at
perhaps a four-year deal worth between
80 and 100 million dollars it's hard to
believe because
if you look at the last three years he's
only played in 125 games
the first year was one game the next
year i think it was about
70 plus games but he was mostly a backup
and that was that first year back from
injury
this year was 52 and he didn't play that
well and he wasn't really good
in the playoffs but it only takes one
team and a team like the knicks the
atlanta hawks
they're looking to make big moves so it
looks like gordon hayward will likely be
on the move
i think what the lakers are hoping i'm
sorry what the celtics are hoping
is that he will agree to a sign in trade
so maybe they can get something back for
him
but see i why are the knicks doing this
and then they're going to bring back
carmelo
i got it it just felt like you got ob
topping who's a wonderful kid
i don't like rj barrett's good
like just can they just be complacent
patient here for a little while and not
go for the guy that's a big ticket item
who's
coming off injuries or at the end of his
career well
i would say this i think that tom
thibodeau wants to win now
when i mean win now i think he wants to
be a playoff team and the only thing i
would say about that look at the move
now it's a different player but if you
look at the move that the phoenix suns
made
they haven't made the playoffs for 10
straight years and chris paul
has been in the playoffs for 10 straight
years and a couple years ago everyone
would have said that's the last guy you
want on your team
because of that contract look what he
did to oklahoma city last year a team
that a lot of people thought wouldn't be
a playoff team
so everyone's value on that team
increased because chris paul was there
including dennis schroeder who just got
traded to the lakers
so i think if you're the knicks there
comes a point dan
where you just can't be young all the
time it's about being
good it's about getting better i say it
all the time if you want to be young and
athletic
just draft a track team from a college
you know get a bunch of 20 year olds and
run up and down that that's not what
it's about
sacramento has not made the playoffs for
14 straight years
they're young and i think the phoenix
suns are in the same boat
where they figured we have to make a
move and that's why i think if you're
the knicks
why not get a couple of veteran players
try to make the play if you need to
change the perception of the
organization
because the perception of the
organization is you're dysfunctional and
you're never good enough
but if i look at the celtics situation
like are they
is there another move there for danny
ainge and the celtics are they they go
in status quo i think they're you know
if they end up losing
gordon hayward for nothing it's it's
definitely a setback
now he wasn't the player that they
thought they were getting the injury
obviously had a lot to do with that and
they're in a tough situation as well
with kemba walker who all of a sudden
all that wear and tear on the knee is
catching up to them
and he struggled in the bubble as well
so this would be a major setback
for the celtics in a year where you know
look at the moves that daryl mori is
already making
could they make a play for james harden
you know the nets are going to be better
toronto that situation's in flux but if
they run it back with everybody they'll
still be a tough team
the atlantic division is very good and
it looks like the knicks are getting
better
as well so boston will be to me if
boston doesn't have a player
similar to gordon hayward a talented
scoring type of forward
they're going to take a step back and
this was a team that was a conference
finalist last year or this a couple of
months ago
if you ran the rockets what would you do
with james harden
to me it's it's frustrating and this is
why you know we talk all the time
about player empowerment and players
love it the
union loves it fans seem to like it
people in the media love it all right so
player empowerment works when it's
lebron so he goes to miami and he throws
his weight around and he brings players
there they win a title he does it in
cleveland
he does it in la he wins a title kawhi
was all about player empowerment he went
out to
la and he said you need to get paul
george here then i'll come so they move
heaven and earth trade all these assets
to get paul george and what happens
they don't play well they don't even get
out of the second round and doc rivers
loses his job
so player empowerment is great for a
player because you're never held
accountable so james harden did the same
thing he didn't want chris paul on the
team anymore they trade all these assets
so oklahoma city will take that contract
and now james harden wakes up one day
doesn't want to play
for the rockets anymore to me if on the
rockets if i can get ben simmons i'm
getting seven years younger
he's been an all-star before in the
league to me that makes sense
i cannot trade him to the brooklyn nets
and i like spencer dinwiddie and cary
sivert and jared allen
terrific role players but you're going
to be a lottery team
in the western conference and when your
lottery team your pick belongs to
oklahoma city
so sam presti is rooting for the houston
rockets
to trade james harden to the brooklyn
nets because oklahoma city will end up
with those picks
yeah it is amazing though that he said
hey i don't want to play with chris paul
i want russell westbrook and then all of
a sudden he wakes up and he goes no i
don't i don't want to do this anymore
and if i'm
the rockets i'm not in any hurry to
trade nope james harden
i want two teams to be involved and i
wonder about this frank
i still think if you said i'm gonna get
james harden i'd rather have james
harden with ben simmons than i would
joel embiid
because i don't think joel embiid's
gonna go hey let me just stand around
and watch him jack up 30 shots a game
he wants to be a star thinks he's a star
ben simmons to me
would be more of uh an accompaniment a
compliment to james harden as a player
than joel embiid would
i happen to agree with you it's funny
just a little while ago i looked it up
on embiid
he's been in the league six years he's
played in 209 regular season games
lebron has played in 260 playoff games
in his career and that's the thing
embiid is a terrific player but the way
the nba is going kind of going away from
the big man
and to me he's not available enough and
the one thing about harden
people could beat him up all they want
you know some of the playoff moments
that he's had where he checked down that
one game against san antonio
hasn't played well the last couple of
years they had golden state on the ropes
he didn't play well
during the regular season the guy plays
he's like he's the throwback he lives
hard
he goes out all the time but guess what
he shows up and he plays and he's
productive
and ben simmons is six foot ten could
handle the ball
whenever people ask you to you know
decide between the two of them i'm with
you
i always say ben simmons just because
for me
the skill the athleticism and to me he's
only going to get better you just worry
about embiid with that foot injury that
he's had
he's frank isola who was on around the
horn and pardoned the interruption and
he has a show on siriusxm
nba radio the starting lineup monday
through friday 7 a.m to 10 a.m
lakers make any moves here in free
agency
well you know jerriann grant is a player
that they'd love to have an athletic
wing player i don't believe that they
can get him
but i think they made a really good move
getting dennis schroeder now rondo
brought
great leadership to that team last year
played very well
especially in the playoffs but i think
what's going to happen
with the lakers they'll always be those
players late in the season whether or
not they get bought out or guys that
they'll sign for minimum deals
lebron is still at the top of his game
and we'll see how they manage his games
in his minutes during the season but do
you think rondo's gone
i i do think he's got i had heard that
atlanta is going to offer him two years
15 million but his preference believe it
or not is to play for the clippers
i i don't know why that is is you have a
relationship with ty lue that could be
part of it so i think the clippers are
definitely in on him so if rondo were to
leave
i think he would end up with the
clippers but lebron is still so good
and anthony davis is like the perfect
second player because i think anthony
davis
is fine with lebron still being the guy
and there were times where you could
tell lebron was carrying
anthony davis you know davis gets hurt a
lot he leaves games he ends up coming
back
in but i i think anthony davis even the
way we perceive him now has changed
because he played with lebron in one
entire think about the guys that
lebron's won a title with chris bosh
kevin love
kyrie irving now anthony davis he's done
a lot for the the careers of those
of those players what kind of team is
golden state going to be this year
i mean i think they'll struggle to make
the playoffs just because the western
conference
is so good and it stinks because we all
love klay thompson he's a great guy
terrific player unbelievable shooter the
kelly uber move is interesting so if
they're going to trade for him and that
14 million dollars
is because of luxury taxes basically 82
million dollars
you mean to tell me in today's nba with
all the scouting that we have every team
has 100 scouts and they have all these
development coaches
you can't find a player somewhere in the
g-league
that comes i get it you can't find
someone that comes close to what klay
thompson does
you can't find someone that come close
to doing what kelly uber
does which essentially isn't gonna cost
you 82 million dollars wait explain that
all right well he makes 14 million and
because now they they'll be over the
luxury tax
that really comes out to about um
like i said 66 million a luxury taxi you
had the two of them
it's 82 million just to add kelly uber
to the team that's how much he puts you
over the luxury tax that's what i don't
understand
you can't there's nobody that you can
find a cheaper alternative
are they panicking a little bit kelly
uber is a good player but for 82 million
dollars
i don't know about that for one year
frank always great to
see you thanks for joining us and uh
happy thanksgiving my best to all the uh
pti and around the horn folks and thanks
for joining us on short notice
thanks dan same to your guys that's uh
frank isola and uh
the starting lineup monday through
friday 7 a.m to 10 a.m on siriusxm
nba radio